everybody asks what do you think of ello
all right all right all right I get it I
get it it's been building it's been
building first of all I'm on LOA lot of
people don't know that cuz it's ello /
vaynerchuk cuz somebody squatted gary
vee give it back give it back uh I think
ellos got some problems I think that
when you raise venture capital money
like ello did 430,000 i'm here in 435
there's a little bit of a problem there
because they're gonna have to build a
business model and so the question
becomes if they're not going to sell
your data that means they're gonna have
to charge you and so my question for you
and leave it in the comments this could
be the question of the day along with
give me some of the feedback for if
you're gonna pay four bucks per episode
is and then critique the episode by the
way I want to make a stake in the ground
here for episode 27 too many of you were
literally answering the questions and I
get all excited to come in and see what
you guys think about today's episode can
we have a holistic answer especially for
your hardcore veiniacs and the
vaynernation can you guys do me a favor
the 150 400 of you that can you could
critique the episodes and tell me this
was for example today you can say this
is by far the best one ever because you
went into such detail I took a lot out
of it like can you give me that like
your muscles look bigger like can you
give me like critiques and then you can
answer the question day today's question
day jumping in backwards is will you pay
ten dollars a month for ello ok but like
back into that if look they're in a
business model vc's want returns on
their investment they didn't just do it
for kicks and giggles these guys gals
people part of the team they need to
build a product that delivers on that
that is the intent or at least somewhat
eat you know the question becomes are
they going to charge you for it because
that's really the only other angle in a
social network to really drive there and
they may come up with something
innovative and God bless and I'm rooting
for everybody all the time my big thing
is people don't care that you're selling
their data that's right let me say it
again people don't care because the
dirty little secret we're going to look
back at this video in 3 years 6 years 9
years and I'm going to look smart again
which is this we actually want ads
better targeted I actually want to see
Lionel Richie and root beer ads when I'm
in the market for another pair of pumas
or another pair of Nikes I can normally
where I want to see sneaker ads we want
to see them way way way more than you
think and somebody will jump in the
comments three or four of you and say no
no no cool fine but the data my gut my
intuition the things I'm seeing is will
take them if they're good once they stop
being ads and they start being content
that's the forefront of what I'm trying
to push here that's what's going on back
here when it actually brings you value
and then okay it sells you you know like
sports like I actually like sports no
wonder i buy jerseys get it so a couple
things one I think it's structured with
some vulnerabilities to this has
happened a bunch of times and we've seen
this a bunch of times the sporah all
this stuff this happens a lot three so
far I'm not in love with the product
that much though I do like that they're
moving and they're making changes so big
ups to that team my intuition early on
is I don't know I don't see it like
becoming the next Facebook by any
stretch of the imagination that being
said this is not normally in the process
where I draw a line and make a
prediction and many times that I'm not
Nostradamus I just know when to react
it's too early for me to make my final
call want to see more behavior but my
intuition is they're going to come out
and charge you or do something else that
is going to turn off a lot of people not
to mention not as many people
theoretically are you know excuse me too
many people theoretically like the
notion but then when it comes to
actuality like we like a lot of things
in theory but then we don't act on them
this feels like one of them for me